guys who are you and what have you come
with today witness soldier got the older
pony calm in there and then I'm Kyle
Rayner but this is my own design because
normally he's a Green Lantern and this
is my own look of him being a Red
Lantern what was the inspiration behind
being a Red Lantern
I've been reading the Red Lantern since
Jeff Jones wrote it in blackest night
and they've always been my second
favorite Lantern Corps and so yeah I
just really enjoyed the comics and I
thought why not make this costume so I
did
so how tough is it putting these
costumes together because they look
pretty impressive painting you asked
this is actually the Maktoob suit I've
added knee pads changed some pockets
round of a second jacket redid the arm
new gloves as I'll be near enough
restarted the entire costume super
comic-con was my first ever time costume
in and I see I look for the fighters and
wear yeah that's not good enough
all right we'll start all over again and
basically since Super Comic Con so
February I've been slowly going through
getting bits here and there and then
basically for my last three weeks
leading up to it I've got seamstress and
it was fittings and sizing and all the
rest of it so yeah some dedication isn't
it how about you Ben
well this took me about a good three or
four days to make like I ordered this
for my friend and this
but black Santa suit they made all the
gloves and the boots just sewed these
onto him souls and but the problem is
our spandex is very stretchy material so
if you're going to wear it over
something be sure to like mark out three
or four times and just be careful where
you stitch a very good tip is it's super
hot in those costumes it's quite hot on
the floor here it's very common our Mars
had been playing up so much I mean
yesterday we both did how Jordan and we
tried to get John Street as well we can
go on but the amount of people that were
brunette Nicole grabbed a photo so that
was pretty cool but yeah I mean we
probably got to reapply the mask about
four times just cuz it wasn't getting so
hot that the masks were just falling off
I mean mines mines already starting to
come off a little bit already we've been
in here about an hour already so yeah
it's quite warm I hope it stays with you
for the rest of the day that's all I'm
saying if the Vice you're density was
ruin it and everyone will know who you
are unveiled here at Kapow so guys are
you gonna be hoping to win something
today and their cosplay contest
oh yeah we're definitely gonna give it a
go I'm gonna go in there I've made some
fake boat last night tip only used one
ball of blood red food dye and syrup one
bowl of syrup not to just one under that
and one of that that's it you don't need
any more than that you sound like a man
who's speaking from experience bad I
tried this on last Friday and it was a
bit missing I'm living this I'm living
all these tips as well on like what to
do the cost to you and the fake blood
and sir that's great I think the best
thing to do is find a perfect reference
that you want and go right right because
so many different artists just draw the
same character so many different ways
you want to find the one you like and go
that's the one I'm doing I mean witness
soldiers I've seen three different
versions and I went no that's the one I
want I mean I pick the version front
covers on the new comic and he's got
like the segmented arm and stuff I was
like that's the one I want and that's
what I'm working on really well like I
said before you both look great
good luck with the cosplay contest you
do well already thank you and great to
speak to you yeah good to speak to you
you